hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play scp-432
now this guy was very quick and getting
a version out of a real playable full
version like uh just a few days after I
gave my video so kudos for him for
getting it out so fast so there's
actually a goal now you gotta find the
box before the monster gets yeah so
changed monster changed ending change
sounds chain menu change what is this oh
hey that's me hey thanks for making a
let's play mark you're welcome I'm
guessing that's me because I'm the only
mark that I know yeah
hi that's cool alright cool alright here
we go to turn up the volume on that okay
so all familiar setting god I'd love
that music I don't know what that's from
is that from anything
okay so gotta find the box if I remember
there's a dead end of the right so I
don't want to go that way ooh
visibility seems to be limited if I
don't know if that's any more or less
pronounced and it was but there's a box
in here that I need to find I'm not
gonna quit until I find it that in that
way - I know that what happened I died
how I guess the death is still just as
pronounced as it was before
I didn't see anything coming Oh nothin
it was just um
there was no warning no rhyme or reason
hmm come on brah I'm not looking at you
your eyes are a bit wider did you get
some derp in yo what do I do about you
will ow hey it worked the full ow
is unstoppable let's go left this time
oh this was a dead end too okay however
they do not remember where I was or what
I'm doing there is no sprint I am on my
own and probably about to die maybe I
should check to see if it's around me
what's this oh yeah I remember kind of
changed here ah that music is so
deliciously diabolical dead-ends ah
Wow Wow whiff Wow
oh you disappeared
hello is anybody here
is there a monster in here uh-huh okay
moving back gotta find a box what's in
the box what's in the box I don't even
know if I'm going backwards the way I
came or if I got turned around somewhere
I'm not exactly sure my only hope is to
come I saw a leg ah come on I saw like a
leg balls
aloni
all right oh it shows more warning
before I got murdered get murdered get
murdered let's go to the right hi
bye thank you go to hell and die yep
still at an end
dad an end pin end Oh what's up monster
you think you can take the great and
powerful markiplier probably I've been
taken many times before ah that's right
right away he's prize startled by my
sexual innuendo and your end oh ok this
is a PG channel or dumb like that
[Music]
no I'm not gonna make a jump-scare in
this video like I did before I mean what
are you talking about I didn't do
anything in the last video what do you
mean did something happen oh okay so I
don't see a box kind of been wandering
for quite a while now
and I think I've covered most of the
area in here I'm gonna start hitting
dead ends again I thought yeah ah what
did i do what did i do my light bulb
exploded and apparently that means I
died what am i doing what am I doing
wrong
hmm seems like there still needs to be
some kinks worked out a new game but
like I said this guy got it out really
quickly so there's no doubt gonna be
some changes that still need to be made
but still the environment ah hi there
you are oh it's just a yeah I still okay
alright there we go that was him oh okay
he's hey he's up big a he's a big boy
he's got those her arms not legs those
are friend links so he's like four four
pronged whatever but it's like I don't
even have to be looking at him for him
to get me just has so happened at that
time he was right in front of me happy
fun times hey I see ya ah
I'll getcha Oh what are you doing oh
he's coming towards me he's like a goat
he cuts right through the wall that's
not even fair look at him hi have you so
he just got a I just got a BA hey uh hi
foo Clow hey he's coming it's slowly
coming his way it's like he comes in
random directions but I don't know where
the fook this blocks is what is he hi hi
dick
done what he had done are you done how
about you go screw yourself
huh yeah it's good so I thought yeah it
definitely needs to be some kinks worked
out because the terror factor of that
monster is diminishing quickly I mean no
offense to the game maker but I mean
it's just it's a simple McKenney the box
I found the box
all right there we go I found the box
and then the monster catch me that means
I won catched me caught me yeah that was
obviously still some things didn't need
to be worked out in terms of you know
pathfinding for the monster instead of
just a straight shot it's gonna be
dynamic and stuff like that but either
way that's a good start it's very
atmospheric gameplay it's just the
mechanics of the monster needed to be
tweaked to make it a more immersive and
terrifying experience because I mean
it's startling to just be randomly
caught but it's more frightening for
there to be a reason for you to be
afraid like you need to be afraid you
can't just be randomly caught because
that destroys the emergent because
you're not actually there people know
that they're not actually in the place
but if they feel like they need to run
away from something terrifying that's
scarier but anyway good potential like I
said still good potential I'm glad that
we got some actual goal in there and
mechanics in there so good job keep it
up I'll play it when you got some big
when you got some big changes I might
play it again so thank you all so much
for watching click the annotation for
more videos that I've done and as always
I will see you in the next video bye
[Music]
Oh oh no that did not do it that didn't
do it that did not do it oh oh oh no oh
no oh no oh no that's it oh no that so
that's all those that told you oh no get
out of here oh wow
why did I do that right why why why did
I do